et on continue d'en parler avec notre
invité françois poulet mathis il est
journaliste et spécialiste de l'europe
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france on
est de le voir le conseil
constitutionnel polonais annonce donc
que le droit polonais prime sur le droit
européen
pourquoi at il été saisie sur cette
question on imagine bien que ça
intervient à un moment précis
mais je crois qu'il faut revenir en
arrière il faut revenir à cette décision
extrêmement importante du gouvernement
polonais effectivement c'est de
reprendre d'une certaine manière le
contrôle de sa justice en reprenant le
contrôle de sa justice par finalement le
fonctionnement de ce tribunal
constitutionnel je précise bien qu'il
s'agit d'un tribunal constitutionnel et
non pas d'une cour constitutionnelle
eh bien on re en essayant de reprendre
le contrôle sur la justice effectivement
la pologne de fait se met à l'extérieur
de l'union européenne pourquoi parce que
c'est des choses que effectivement
souvent on ne comprend pas la primauté
du droit européen sur le droit national
c'est quelque chose qui est une règle
commune que tous les pays les 27 pays de
l'union ont accepté de manière tout à
fait souveraine ils ont accepté de
mettre en commun ses fondements du droit
qui fonde finalement notre règle commune
ça n'empêche pas effectivement certains
des pays d'avoir leur propre loi à
condition que ces lois ne viennent pas
en contradiction or ce qui se passe avec
le la pologne c'est que sur deux sujets
fondamentaux la pologne se met en
contradiction avec les valeurs
essentielles du droit européen
ces deux ce sujet sont d'une part la
séparation des pouvoirs séparation entre
justice entre pouvoirs législatifs
pouvoir exécutif c'est un fondement
essentiel de toute démocratie
parlementaire et puis deuxième important
de l'image peu important le respect des
minorités je pense notamment à ces
régions polonaises qui ont décidé de
s'affranchir de la reconnaissance de
population lgbt donc là on est sur deux
sujets qui sont qui font partie de la
charte fondamentale des droits des
droits européens
donc c'est en cela que lapointe
effectivement se met en contradiction
sion avec le droit et aujourd'hui on se
trouve devant cette situation un peu
paradoxale c'est que deux fêtes la
pologne est en dehors des clous des
règles de l'union européenne même si
elle affirme ne vouloir y rester on ne
peut pas rester dans une union si on
n'accepte pas les règles de base c'est
un peu ce qui se passe des raisons pour
laquelle à bruxelles effectivement on
envisage aujourd'hui des sanctions parce
qu'on ne peut pas laisser passer ça
effectivement ce serait la porte ouverte
finalement à détricotage générale de
l'union européenne et varsovie en voilà
mais sa sphère à l'union européenne ça
veut dire qu'elle ne reconnaît pas
finalement les différents jugements que
l'union européenne pourrait émettre
quant à ces réformes intérieures
voilà mais effectivement l'union
européenne portent des jugements en ce
qui concerne les fondements du droit
elle ne porte pas de jugement sur des
aspects très précis du droit c'est par
exemple une différence entre les
déclarations qu'a pu faire un michel
barnier à l'époque qui voulait
s'affranchir de cette certaines règles
de l'union européenne en matière
d'immigration ou même encore aujourd'hui
ce qu'arnaud montebourg lui-même prétend
vouloir sortir un petit peu de certaines
seynois cd question effectivement qui
sont graves mais ils sont pas aussi
grave que la position dans laquelle est
en train de se battre la pologne parce
que la pologne tout simplement elle est
en train de mettre sous tutelle sa
justice or ça on touche un point
fondamental des valeurs du droit des
valeurs européennes l'estran 5
finalement il peut pas y avoir de
compromis là-dessus raison pour laquelle
que peut faire l'union européenne c'est
difficile parce que il y a actuellement
deux pays dans l'union européenne qui
manifeste un petit peu ces réactions
d'opposition au droit européen au sens
large du terme c'est la pologne et la
hongrie il faut savoir que quand deux
pays effectivement se met dans cette
position ça rend très difficile des
sanctions mais l'europe a quand même des
moyens des moyens de réagir et notamment
il n'ya 36 milliards d'euros qui sont
attendus très rapidement par la pologne
qui sont importants pour son propre plan
de relance est bien par exemple cette
manne de 36 milliards d'euros peut être
actuellement bloquée c'est un petit peu
ce qui se passe actuellement voilà
l'europe n'est pas totalement dépourvus
de moyens mais effectivement là il ya le
début d'un vrai divorce entre deux pays
l'union et l'ensemble de l'union et donc
la pologne n'accepte plus la règle
commune certains parlent déjà de pau
lexique est ce que selon vous c'est
prématuré
c'est un peu prématuré parce que la
pologne effectivement n'est pas prête à
quitter l'union européenne d'ailleurs la
population polonaise dans son ensemble
est extrêmement favorable au maintien de
la pologne dans l'union européenne il
n'y a pas comme dans d'autres pays comme
par exemple ça pouvait être le cas au
royaume uni il n'y a pas de majorité
même faible pour quitter l'union
européenne la très grande majorité des
polonais veulent rester dans l'union
européenne on peut simplement se
demander si leur volonté de rester dans
l'union européenne
qu'est ce qui compte le plus est ce que
c'est les avantages économiques d'un
maintien dans l'union ou est ce que
c'est la réalité effectivement d'être
dans l'union en épousant toutes ces
valeurs là il ya de vraies questions il
faudra peut-être un jour crever cet
abcès
françois poulin et mathis merci pour
votre éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste de l'europe
merci à vous